even some long time Democrats are
realizing it here is Democrat city
councilman Robert Holden talking about
how bad it has gotten in New York
71 years I've lived in New York City
I've seen bad times high crime 2 000
murders a year in the 80s I've not seen
the lawlessness that I'm seeing today in
New York City in my lifetime that means
we're afraid to go anywhere guys he's a
Democrat 71 years in New York City a
Democrat I've never seen it like this so
which do you think he's just a liar like
is he just absolutely lying are the
videos that you see all the time are
they just fabricated nonsense
or is it that Eric Adams is lying right
like which one is it you just have to
pick one and I think you guys know which
one probably is true and you know it's
probably true because of the policies
that uh DA's District Attorneys like
Alvin Bragg who's going after Donald
Trump in a I would argue a criminal
fashion uh he refuses to prosecute real
criminals here's uh representative Jim
Jordan talking about that
I mean think about this fact
327 individuals have done six thousand
of the theft crimes in this city yeah
they call them theft crimes we used to
call it stealing taking other people's
property so 300 and some people 327
people six now that's that's 20 arrests
but that's 20 times that each of these
individuals have done this on average
well maybe lock them up after the first
or the second or maybe the 19th time so
they don't do it the 20th time but
that's what's going on here and in
cities all over the country and it's why
what was the set I think I saw on on
your show last week where it sounded
like 27 of New Yorkers want to move out
of the state they want to move out of
here and it's driven by this crime
Factor so Jim Jordan is painting this
problem with a really simple paintbrush
guys small minority of people are
responsible for a huge majority of the
crime how about we get them but the
problem is that the left actually
believes Eric Adams all of these people
Lori Lightfoot Etc et cetera they
believe that the criminals aren't the
problem and I really believe that they
believe that the system is the problem
the criminal is just a symptom it's the
system of capitalism and the patriarchy
and blah blah blah that lead these
people to Maul people on the streets and
push Asian women into Subways and burn
down Pep Boys and loot targets and
everything else so they they actually
have more Sympathy for the criminal than
they have for the victims of their
criminal Behavior
foreign
[Music]